hi everyone mad luigi here with another
elden ring video today discussing not an
aspect of the game but of the community
elden ring is a beautiful game with
wonderful art and visual design so it
shouldn't come as a surprise that the
game has inspired a whole host of
wonderful fan art i've been fortunate
enough to feature a lot of that art in
my video thumbnails and today i want to
take a moment to celebrate this artistic
aspect of the community from my first
lore video i've gotten the chance to
showcase some stunning fan art my godric
video featured a slightly abstract
character study of the grafted lord this
piece was made by alex langenick before
the game came out they have an instagram
and a personal website showcasing more
art in a similar style which i think
does a great job of capturing moods and
feelings in its own very stylized way
unfortunately there don't look to be any
more else in ring pieces but a lot of
the other work does fit right in with
the similar dark oppressive and weird
themes of the game
next is from my morgue video which
features a stunning depiction of the
grace given king with all his melancholy
and sense of duty oozing from the art
this piece was done by a user coasting
on twitter who also has a tumblr page
for their art they have other art in the
same style not only from eldon ring but
also from other fromsoft games like
securo and dark souls the morgot piece
might still be my favorite with its
great capturing of emotion but the cute
kali and pod pieces are pretty great too
after morgot comes the great second
elden lord ratagan drawn by one of the
most prolific fan artists in the
community shimek you can find more of
their art on their twitter or instagram
pages in addition to being able to
purchase prints on sites like redbubble
they have a whole host of wonderful
pieces on many of the significant
characters of eldon ring tons of bosses
the player character and even let me
solo her have found artful depictions
here and i can't recommend checking out
this work enough it's really great and
some custom pieces have even been
featured by other elden ring content
creators like smotown and oro boris
back to the cuter side of things my
torrent video features a picture of art
from march 3 range who posts their art
on instagram the work i used is a warm
snapshot of melania riding touring and
while there aren't other elden ring
works there are plenty of similarly cute
and warming works of art on their page
with topics ranging from characters to
people to snacks food and even a prawn
which one could say counts as elden ring
art finally the last piece of art i've
gotten to feature on my channel so far
is a wonderful depiction of the festival
of radon by the talented adrian le cause
you can find adrian's works on instagram
and you can purchase print files on
patreon or redbubble the style is
reminiscent of works depicting epics
with many character studies of the
important players in the lands between
the amount of detail and storytelling
that adrian is able to aesthetically fit
into the works depicting ronnie mikala
and melania is stunning a wonderful
blend of unique art and impressive
detail
so those are all of the artists that you
have seen on my channel and there are
plenty more either doing one-offs of
eldon ring content or consistently
putting out game related works as a
member of the community eldon ring is a
beautiful game with a ton of
eye-catching vistas and landscapes
seeing inspires so many additional
artists is fantastic and i think it
really adds to the experience of the
game to get to see and appreciate this
fan art if you're looking to see more
simply googling elden ring fan art
brings up a lot of results and you can
whittle it down by specifying a certain
character or game area you can also
check out the elden ring subreddit as
that's where i've seen a lot of these
great pieces for the first time there's
even an elden ring art subreddit
specifically dedicated to fan art though
it is a bit smaller than the main one
i hope this video has been a nice
perusing of some of the community's art
and hopefully it has exposed some of you
to the fan art for the first time the
artists deserve a grand congratulations
for their work and if any of these have
really caught your attention you can go
support the artists directly by buying
their work and i apologize to any of the
artists if i mispronounced your name
there's a good chance that that might
have happened
that will do it for this video i just
wanted to make a quick showcase to
spread the word about this great art and
to say another thanks to the artists for
allowing me to use their work on my
channel i hope you've all enjoyed the
video subscribe if you want to see more
and let me know in the comments if you
have a favorite piece of elden ring fan
art this video has been another of the
scheduled pieces i've made because when
this video releases i'm not currently
making videos it's not my core lore or
deep dive but those will continue once i
get back to making videos at the end of
this month thank you all for watching
and i'll see you in the next video peace